donc c'est un moment important parce que
l'est étant il a besoin de rééquilibrage
du territoire a besoin qu'on s'occupe
d'elle encore plus que dans les autres
territoires et on sent que c'est un
moment important parce qu'on ressent
l'engouement des partenaires c'est ça
qui m'a marqué au cours de cette journée
c'est de créer une ceinture routière qui
commencerait dans les hauts de sainte
marie et qui se poursuivraient sur
ceinture des mi pente qui se
poursuivrait jusqu'à saint benoît et
après il y aura raccordement directement
à travers la rd3 sur la commune de
sainte rose c'est d'avoir une voie
parallèle en quelque sorte à la route
nationale pour désenclaver les eaux pour
être une voie de substitution à cette
route nationale pour aller à la
reconquête des terres en friche et que
reconquête agricole c'est le coeur de
métier du département pour créer des
zones d'urbanisation nouvelles des
quartiers nouveau voir des villes
nouvelles
bref c'est un projet structurant global
de développement du territoire est dans
un an on aura un rendu avec trois tracés
possibles et à ce moment là on ira vers
la population la disant voilà les enjeux
voilà le coût du projet est ce qu on y
va où on n'y va pas et si il ya toujours
cette unanimité ce que je pense que je
souhaite
eh bien on lancera ce projet d'envergure
et nous l'objectif c'est d'être prêt
pour la profusion programmation des
fonds européens pour 2020 qu'on soit
éligible à ces fonds parce qu'on en aura
besoin pour développer concrètement ce
projet